après 2005 je me rappelle elle me
contrôle experts tels que la santé
ensemble 7 6 avait fait sur un terrain
vrai en 2005-2006 en prime time
il avait chanté couler douce était un
prime time spécial chaque chanteur
faisait un duo avec une personnalité
oui avec thierry ouais c'est moi qui
avais choisi s'est choisi on s'était
choisi on s'est reconnus déjà ça fait
onze ans il va chez tf1 il vous retrait
la naufrage moi vous pardonne à voter
qu'est-ce qui se passe non c'est à dire
il faut pas oublier qu'il a une dette
non elle a peu plus tard on dit la
vérité ce côté là je ne sens pas vous
c'est quoi au matin jour vous vous êtes
dans le public attend qu il attend jury
de nouvelle star
voilà qui met attend m appelle deux
salles avec timbaland
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est 2008 ça il est bon on s'en est
créé et écrit maman frais à moi je sais
pas ce que j'ai pu lire çà là c'est une
de mes préférées
[Musique]
là
honda
ce que je travaille un petit peu j'ai
revu tous les types mp crash aussi est
ce que tu te rends compte tous les tubes
qui l'a fait sans déconner et nos
missions et c'est ouf ça tu t es qui toi
est ce que quand on est chanteur comme
toi succès ce qu'on écoute ses chansons
non non on les écoute pendant qu'on fait
l'album gars prennent en studio et quand
il est sorti on les a tellement écouté
pour faire les retouches ce qu'on
voulait modifier tous que la loi met
sortie c'est vous et moi dans la voiture
je m'affole d'abord à 9 à huawei
[Applaudissements]